we're told suppose that eight percent of
all cars produced at plant
a have a certain defect and six percent
of all cars produced at plant b have
this defect
each month a quality control manager
takes separate
random samples of 200 of the over 3000
cars produced from
each plant the manager looks at the
difference between the proportions of
cars
with the defect in each sample so
they're looking at the difference of
sample proportions every month
describe the distribution of the
difference of sample proportions in
terms of its mean
standard deviation and shape so let's
take these
step by step so first let's think about
the mean
of the difference of our sample
proportions pause this video and try to
figure out what that's going to be
well we have seen this in previous
videos that if we have the mean
of the difference of two random
variables that's the same as the
difference of the means or another way
to think about it is
if we want to figure out the mean of
this so sample proportion from plant a
minus sample proportion from plant b
this is just going to be equal to
the mean of the sample proportion from
plant a
minus the mean of the sample proportion
from plant b
now what are these going to be equal to
well what's the mean
of the sample proportion of plant a
it's just going to be the true
population proportion
for plant a and they tell us that they
tell us that 8 percent
of all cars produced at plant a have a
certain effect
so this could be eight percent or we
could write it as 0.08
and then from that we are going to
subtract the
mean of the sample proportion from plant
b
and we know what that means going to be
the mean of a sample proportion
is going to be the population
proportion the parameter of the
population which we know
for plant b is six percent zero 0.06
and then that gets us a mean of the
difference of 0.02
or 2 percent having a or 2 percent
difference in defect rate would be
the mean now let's think about
the standard deviation so instead of
thinking in terms of standard deviation
let's think about
the square of the standard deviation
which is variance and from there
we can go back to standard deviation by
taking a square root
so if we're looking at the variance and
let me write it this way
if we're looking at the variance of the
difference
of the sample proportions so the sample
proportion from plant a
minus the sample proportion from plan b
but just as a review
if you assume that we're sampling
independently from
each of the plants so what we're
sampling from plant a does not affect
what we're sampling from plant b
or vice versa then we can add
the variances so this is going to be
equal to
the variance of the sample proportion
from plant a
plus the variance of the sample
proportion from plan b some of you might
be saying wait aren't we taking the
difference of sample proportions here
why are we adding
and the reminder is remember variance is
a measure of
spread and whether you're now taking the
difference of
random variables or you're taking the
sum of them when you have more variables
you're going to have more spread
so regardless of whether this is a
negative or a positive over here
this is going to be a positive so what
is this going to be equal to
well we could take each of these terms
what's going to be the variance of the
sample proportion from plant a
well if every time we looked at one of
the
cars we looked at it and then we put it
back into the mix so if we were sampling
with replacement
which means that each of our
observations are independent of the
other ones
we have a formula we know that this
variance would be
the population proportion of plant a
times 1 minus the population proportion
of plant a
divided by the number that we sampled
from plant a
now in the scenario that we are talking
about we didn't sample
with replacement we just took 200 at a
time and looked at them we didn't take
one at a time
and replace it and do that 200 times but
we also know that this is a pretty good
approximation even when you are not
sampling with replacement if your sample
is
less than 10 of the population and 200
is
less than 10 percent of 3000 so this is
a pretty good
approximation what you would use in a
first year statistics class
and of course we can use the same logic
this is going to be equal to
the population proportion in plan b
times 1 minus the population proportion
in plant b
all of that over your sample size from
plant b and we know
all of these things we know that your
population proportion in plant a
is eight percent or 0.08
one minus that is 0.92
we're taking samples of 200 at a time
from plant a
and then in plant b we know the
population proportion they told us
is six percent or 0.06
one minus that is 0.94
and then the sample size from plant b is
also going to be 200
is going to be 200 we get .08
times .92 divided by
200 and then plus
let's open parentheses here we get .06
times 0.94 divided by
200 and then actually let me close the
parentheses
and that equals this business so .00065
so 0.00065
and then from this we can figure out
what the standard deviation is going to
be the standard deviation
of the difference between our sample
proportions
is going to be just the square root of
this it's going to be the square root of
0.00065
and that is approximately equal to
let's just take the square root and we
get this
0.025 5
0.025 and there you have it we have
thought about the standard deviation
and then last but not least let's think
about the shape
so just as a review we just have to
remind ourselves
that the distribution of each sample
proportion
is going to be normal as long as we
expect
at least 10 successes and 10 failures
well let's look at each of these how
many successes do you expect
where success would actually be a defect
but let's think about this
eight percent of in each case of a
sample of 200
that's going to be 16 so you would
expect 16 defects
and then you would expect 200 minus 16
which is a lot larger than 10
of no defects so both of those are
greater than or equal to 10
and then if you did the same thing for
plant b you get the same idea six
percent of 200
is 12 and then if you say the ones that
have no defects that's 200
minus 12 which is way more than 10 in
especially in that latter case but in
every situation
we expect to have at least 10 successes
and 10 failures
and so we can assume that the
distributions of each of these
are going to be normal and we also know
that the difference of two normally
distributed variables
is also normal so long as they pass
that large count condition that we just
talked about and so
let's draw what this distribution might
look like
it might look something like this it's
going to be a normal distribution
where you have a mean
right over here of i'll do that in that
same
color a mean of 0.02
you can definitely take on negative
values because there's some situations
in which your your sample proportion
from plant b
actually could be larger just by random
chance than it is from
plant a so you can definitely take on
negative values but if i wanted to show
where
0 is maybe 0 is right over here
so we could draw an axis right over here
and then we know what the standard
deviation is it's 0.025 or it's
approximately that so if we were to go
one standard deviation down
we would go right about there and if we
were to go one standard deviation up we
would go right about there and obviously
we could go more than
one standard deviation above or below
that mean